Guten Abend, mein Name ist Ulucan. Ich bin hier erst. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiß Miriam Früger.
Miriam Früger. Ja, vorallem Früger. Ich möchte sicher zugehen. Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, der Vorname Miriam, M-I-R-I-A-M. Gut. Und der Familie Name Früger, K-R-U-Umbau, also U-G-E-R.
Okay, frag ruhig. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 36 Jahre alt. 36 Jahre alt. Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 2.05.88. 12.05.
2.05. Okay, 15. Okay.
2.05. Okay.
Ja, Herr Fragrüger. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe seit Tagen solche Bauchschmerzen. Es wird immer schlimmer und mir ist so schlecht.
Ich habe seit 3 Tagen immer wieder Durchfall und musste mich heute auch übergeben.
Ich glaube, das hängt zusammen mit einer Weihnachtsfeier. Wir waren in einem thailändischen Restaurant.
Es gab sehr leckeres Essen, aber es war sehr scharf.
Das bin ich überhaupt nicht gewöhnt. Danach ging es mir schon schlecht.
Das ist aber überhaupt nicht besser. Ich habe gedacht, ich muss jetzt unbedingt zu Ihnen kommen.
Sie haben gut gemacht. Gibt es jemanden, die jenische Beschwerde in Ihrer Umgebung haben?
Nein, die anderen, die dabei waren, haben nichts gesagt. Aber mir geht es wirklich schlecht.
Verstanden. Sie haben seit Tagen...
Vor 3 Tagen war das, da hat es angefangen. Jetzt ist mir immer noch so schlecht.
Es drückt und krampft in meinem Bauch. Ich kann nur so Tee trinken und vielleicht mal ein bisschen Zwieback oder Salzstangen essen.
Ich habe eigentlich das Gefühl, dass es mir gar nicht gut geht.
Die Schmerzen sind krampfertig. Wie viel Mal haben Sie erbrochen?
Heute Morgen 2 Mal.
Wie sieht das Erbrechen aus?
Wie es immer aussieht, das man vorher gegessen hat, vom Tee eingefärbt, Essenrechte oder so etwas.
Ein bisschen Schlein dabei, aber es sieht immer aus.
Es gibt ja etwas, wie Blut, aber nein, ich verstehe sie.
Das war immer der Grund.
Wie viel Mal müssen Sie so zu heute gehen wegen Durchwahl?
Das ist eigentlich von jetzt seit Tagen, gestern und heute, ich würde sagen 3-4 Mal.
Dass immer kleine Mengen kommen, aber dass der Bauch krampft.
Wie sieht das aus?
Ich habe mir nicht so genau hingeguckt.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Im Oberbauch, also oberhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Wie ist das mit der Schmerz?
Am Anfang habe ich gedacht, da hat man ein bisschen Magendrücken, aber jetzt ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Ich habe das jetzt den ganzen Tag ausgehalten.
Gibt es etwas, dass ihr Schmerzen verdient oder verschlechtet?
Ich denke, wenn ich etwas normales gegessen hätte, richtiges gekochtes Essen, dann wäre mir schlecht geworden.
Aber ich habe das gar nicht erst probiert.
Als ich im Bett gelegen habe, mit einer Wärmflasche, hatte ich das Gefühl, dass es besser wird.
Oder nach dem Schulgang, fühlen Sie sich besser?
Ja, nach dem Schulgang, klar.
Da kramft es dann ein bisschen im Bauch und danach fühlt man sich schon erleichtert.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen irgendwo genug?
Nein, ich würde sagen, sie sind im Oberbauchbereich.
Von da aus geht es nirgendwo anders hin.
Sie haben schon Erbrochen, deswegen haben Sie Überkeit.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich fühle mich nicht fieberig, ich habe mich aber nicht gemessen.
Oder nach dem Schulgang, ist Ihnen dann auch geballert?
Nein, so etwas nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Eigentlich hätte ich wohl Hunger, ich würde gerne etwas essen, aber der Gedanke daran,
das lockt mich jetzt im Augenblick gar nicht.
Normalerweise bin ich eigentlich ein guter Äster, kann nicht klagen.
Aber jetzt ist es wirklich so, dass es mir nicht gut schmeckt.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie kein Appetit.
Ja, genau.
Frau Krüger, wie viel wiegen Sie momentan?
Ich wiege 64 kg.
64 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,71.
Haben Sie Gewicht, Veränderung bemerkt?
Nein, das habe ich nicht aufgefallen.
Hatten Sie früher den Ehnische beschwerden?
Ja, eigentlich habe ich das schon relativ lange,
dass ich mal Schmerzen im Oberbau habe.
Ich bin da auch mal bei meinem Hausarzt gewesen.
Das ist jetzt auch schon mehr als ein halbes Jahr her.
Und er hat sogar so eine Untersuchung gemacht,
also so eine Madenspiegelung.
Das hat aber da nichts gefunden.
Und er hat damals gesagt,
vielleicht haben Sie ein bisschen Stress oder so.
Dann haben wir aber nichts weiter gemacht.
Das war einmal oder vielermal?
Ich hatte da immer mal Schmerzen, schon eigentlich lange.
Und wie gesagt, dann bin ich zum Hausarzt gegangen.
Und er hat dann vor einem halben Jahr,
also gut einem halben Jahr, diese Madenspiegelung gemacht.
Aber bei der Madenspiegelung gab es keine Befunde.
Er hat nichts auffälliges gesagt.
Ja, gut.
Ja, schlafen Sie gut?
Weil jetzt die Tage habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen.
Wie gesagt, weil mir schlecht sei, weil ich Bauchweh hatte.
Aber normalerweise kann ich eigentlich ganz gut schlafen.
Ja, haben Sie Billerung gerne so billernen?
Nein, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Jetzt ist es um den Durchfall,
klar habe ich da mal ein bisschen Blähungen mit dabei,
aber normalerweise nicht.
Normalerweise haben Sie so drinnen viel Leid?
Nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen irgendetwas ungewöhnliches etwas
beim Wasser lassen, auch gefallen?
Nein, das ist so wie immer.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich darf keine Erdnüsse essen.
Erdnüsse?
Wie ausstatt ich diese Allergie?
Ja, also ich kriege so ein rotes Gesicht
und die Schleimhäute spälen an.
Das muss ich wirklich vermeiden.
Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Noch nie?
Okay, gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke gerne mal ein Glas Wein.
Also ich habe gerade im Winterabend so ein Glas Rotwein oder so.
Jedem Tag?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also zwei, drei Mal in der Woche vielleicht.
Okay.
Ich habe noch nie einen Alkohol.
Nein, nein, nein. Also zwei, drei Mal in der Woche vielleicht.
Okay, okay.
Ja, Frau Krüger, ich nehme das Sie keine Droge nehmen, oder?
Warum? Ich nehme, also wirklich nicht, nein.
Gut.
Frau Krüger, leiden Sie an irgendetwas kronischer Erkrankungen?
Ja, so kronischer Erkrankungen würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen.
Ich habe vor zwei Jahren meinen Hausarzt mal festgestellt,
dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe.
Blutdruck?
Nehmen Sie da gegen regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, also ich nehme Ramipril, nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Ramipril morgens eine Tablette.
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Oh, ich meine, da steht Ramipril fünf drauf.
Fünf?
Fünf mit dem Gramm.
Ja.
Haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Nein, gut. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, so in der Kindheit habe ich mal den Wandeln raus bekommen, ja.
Mandelentfernung, okay.
Wann war das?
Da war ich acht Jahre alt.
Sie nehmen Ramipril regelmäßig ein und noch weitere Medikamente nehmen Sie an?
Ja, zum Verhüten nehme ich eben noch die Pille, ne?
Pille nehmen Sie, okay.
Wobei das natürlich schlecht ist, jetzt mit übergeben und Durchfall,
da weiß ich, dann muss man sich etwas machen.
Ist Ihre Regelblutung regelmäßig?
Ja, natürlich, klar, durch die Pille wird es gesteuert, ja.
Gut.
Die haben keine Bechwerte relevante Mitregel geblutet.
Noch mal bitte.
Nur.
Okay, gut.
Okay, ich komme jetzt zu Ihrer Familie in der Geschichte.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, ich denke mal, bezug auf Ihr Alter sind die schon ganz gesund.
Mein Vater weiß ich, der hat auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Und dann hatte der mal, ja, der nimmt jetzt glaube ich irgendwelche Medikamente,
weil der mal irgendwie so Herzprobleme hatte.
Der hatte so Vorhoflimmern.
Und da muss er jetzt irgendwie so einen Blutverdenner nehmen.
Verstanden.
Ja, der ist hypertonie und Vorhoff-Pilaman hat ihr Vater.
Okay.
Ihre Mutter?
Ja, die ist eigentlich auch relativ fit, aber die hat halt seit 3 Jahren,
hat man das festgestellt, vor 3 Jahren hat man das festgestellt,
dass sie diesen Alterszucker hat.
Ja, aber das ist nicht irgendwie im aufregenden Bereich.
Die nimmt da glaube ich auch irgendwelche Tabletten,
aber die muss jetzt nicht strenge Diät halten oder so.
Ich kann nicht gut, ich konnte nicht gut verstanden.
Ein Alterszucker.
Alterszucker, gut verstanden, okay.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Eine Schwester, okay.
Ist sie gesund?
Ich ist sie gesund, ja, würde ich sagen, ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter habe ich.
Ist sie gesund?
Die Tochter ist gesund, ja.
Ja, gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Weil ich arbeite Teilzeit als Werbel-Grafikare.
Okay, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich arbeite als Werbel-Grafikerin.
Werbel-Grafikerin, verstanden, gut.
Okay.
Linzigegen, Corona, Grippe oder Kinderkrankheiten
vollgeimpft oder gegen Hepatitis vielleicht?
Oh, jetzt muss ich überlegen, Hepatitis,
puh, sitze ich jetzt nicht.
Ich bin nicht so gegen Kinderkrankheiten, ja klar.
Da haben meine Eltern damals dafür gesorgt.
Und jetzt bin ich aktuell geimpft gegen Grippe, ja klar,
und auch gegen Covid, ja.
Waren Sie in der Stadt im Ausland gewesen?
Ja, ich war einmal in den Niederlanden, aber sonst nicht.
Ja, Frage, ich möchte noch mal fragen,
Sie haben schon gesagt, für sechs Monate waren Sie beim Ars,
wegen ähnlicher Beschwerte.
Ja, verstanden, eine Magelspiegelung wurde durchgeführt
und kapituliert, keine Befunde.
Aber damals hatten Sie Weltebeschwerte, hatten Sie?
Ich hatte halt auch so immer wieder mal Oberbauchschmerzen
nach dem Essen, ne?
Oberbauchschmerzen nach dem Essen.
Ja, in der Civilian-Seite ist Ihnen
die Gegend vielleicht Hautveränderung bemerkt?
Ob ich die Hautveränderung habe,
habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay, Frage, ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen für mich gestattet.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie noch Fragen?
Also Sie haben so viel gefragt, also ich wüsste nicht,
was ich Ihnen jetzt noch ergänzend erzählen kann.
Ja, also ich will natürlich jetzt wissen,
was man gegen die Schmerzen tun kann
und wann das endlich aufhört, ja, kann ja nicht sein.
Das einmal so ein heftiges Essen
mich völlig aus der Bahn wirft, ja.
Das muss irgendwann, muss es ja mal wieder gut werden.
Ja, vor drei Tagen haben Sie eigentlich
und Gebenisches etwas gegessen.
Sie waren im thailändischen Restaurant.
Ja.
Und Ihre Sämtome Beschwerte,
die Beschwerte haben einen Magendarm,
äh, Grippe, Magendarm Erzündung.
Ja, das wegen Sie haben Durcheval,
der Bein.
Ja, natürlich,
Genaet,
fast das Leben,
wir haben ja noch weiter Untersuchungen.
Naht der Ergäpni,
se Könüvia,
äh,
aufs für die Schemitien,
ja,
jetzt werde ich
Ihnen einen Zugang legen
und gleichzeitig Blut abnehmen
und ja, eine Flüssigkeit verabreischen
und Schmerzmittel verabreischen.
Ah, das ist gut.
Ja, natürlich, auf jeden Fall werde ich
zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, gegebenenfalls
Baul, Ultraschall,
oder Stull,
kultur, Stull,
Analys,
Nehmenvia,
äh, ja,
ja, laut der Ergäpni,
se Könüvia,
Daruba, Normal, Beschwerte.
Okay, gut, ja, Dankeschön.
Wir haben das Zeitchenster gut ausgeschürmt.
Noch 90 Minuten über.
Ja.
Gut, möchte ich jemand noch zusätzlich fragen stellen?
Er hat sehr ausstuuliert gefahren,
ne? Ich meine die ganze Frage,
worunter gefragt?
Wo wir uns nicht ganz verständigt haben,
ähm, ich hab nicht gehört,
ähm, ob die Schmerzskala
erwähnt haben.
Ja, ich hab diese Frage gestattet,
aber ich hab die Akustik nicht verstanden.
Ich hab die Akustik nicht verstanden,
und deswegen hab ich mich richtig reagiert,
ähm, und dann haben sie gesagt,
die können wir nachher noch mal fragen.
Ja, ich hab, ich hab, ja, ich hab so verstanden,
Sie haben gesagt, ich könnte nicht genau etwas sagen,
deswegen hab ich nochmal gefragt,
können Sie bis zu meinem Ertrag mit dieser Schmerz?
Ah, genau, das haben Sie gesagt, genau, ja, ja.
Ja, ähm, nee, also,
ich hab, das ist untergegangen bei mir,
ich hatte ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten,
Sie zu verstehen, muss ich sagen,
musste mich sehr, sehr konzentrieren,
und ähm, ja, das ist irgendwie,
ist mir durchgegangen.
Gut, aber ich glaube,
sonst ist wirklich komplett alles gefragt.
Ähm, ja, wie gesagt,
möchte ich jemand noch irgendwas zusätzliches hören?
Was, äh, was haben Sie
im Restaurant gegessen, Fleisch, oder?
Ja, Fleisch und Gemüse,
und es war aber im Extrem scharf,
was ich normalerweise nicht kenne.
Ne, das war mein Problem.
Sie haben gesagt, äh,
dass Sie äh, äh,
äh, äh, aber nach normalen,
nach normalen, ne?
Äh, Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie äh, äh,
und äh,
hat Sie äh,
mit Bauchschmerzen
Erbrechen oder Überkeit,
früher?
Nee, Erbrechen eigentlich nicht, nein,
und Übelkeit minimal.
Das ist neu, ja.
Ja.
Wichtags sind die Schmerzen,
aber in der Skala.
Ja, also am Anfang fing das so an,
mit, äh, mit 4 von 10,
und wenn das so richtig krampft,
ah, dann geht das also, ja,
bis zu 6 oder 7 von 10 schon hoch, ne?
Haben Sie, haben Sie Schwindelgefühlen?
Schwindelgefühlen?
Ja, Schwindel.
Mmm, minimal vielleicht, ja.
Wenn ich schnell aufstehe oder so, ja.
Hmm, ein Doktor, Sie sagen,
Bescheid, wenn Sie als Absprechmann können, ne?
Okay, okay, ich bin bereit.
Ja, dann geht es los.
Mhm.
Ja, guten Abend Frau Oberhals.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin,
äh, Miriam Krüger,
äh,
36-jährige Patientin,
kam zu uns wegen,
während der drei Tage auf Außgetreten
ehm, ehm,ilt Jetrettänder
Die Patientin berichtet, ihre Beschwerden verschlechtern sich nach dem Essen und verbessern nach Defekationen.
Wenn sie auf der Bett legen, ist die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig.
Die Patientin hat Erdnusser, die Allergie außer sich mit Rosesgesicht und Schleimheit ausgeschwollt.
Die Frage, wie Nikotin und Dragun Konsum verleihen werden.
Die Patientin trinkt 2-3 Mal Provohe, 1 Gleis Wein oder im Winter Rotwein.
Die Patientin hat seit 2 Jahren Arterie und Hypertonitis.
Seit 2 Jahren trinkt sie Ramipril für 1 mg morgens.
Mit 8 Jahren hat sie die Tonselektomie und sie nimmt regelmäßig Pille.
Bei der Familienanamnese hat die Arterie und Hypertonitis und Arterie-Fibrillation.
Die Patientin hat eine gesunde Schwester und fragt, ob sie verheiratet hat.
Sie arbeitet als Werbegrifferin.
Die Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Anamnistische Angabe dauert am 1. auf eine Gastroenteritis hin.
Die Differenziatriaknostischkommensfolgen der Erkrankungen betrachten.
Das sind Gastritis, Cholestitis.
Die Verdachsdiagnose ist nicht vollständig.
Das sind zuerst körpeldische Untersuchungen, Blutabnahme,
Abdomenutrachal, Abdomenutrachal, Abdomenutrachal.
Die Gehgebung der Anamnistische Angabe ist eine Differenziatriaknostischkommensfolge.
Ich taste den Abdomen ab.
Ich achte Abwärtsspannung, Druckschmerzen, ob es irgendwelche Hautverfärbung gibt.
Ich baue den Abdomenutrachal.
Was bestimmt die Blutwerte?
Bei der Gastroenteritis erhörte ich die Instrukturparameter.
Ich bin ein Stuttdokultur.
Okay, gut. Ja, was kann man noch sagen? Wenn sich das bestätigt, was ist dann die Therapie?
Ja, sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose erharten, werde ich Folgen der Therapien empfehlen.
Das sind ja auf jeden Fall Flüchtlingskassus.
Ja, vielleicht. Ja, werde ich einen Zugang legen und Flüchtlingskeit verabreichen.
Und ja, gegen jeden Fall nach der Sturkultur, vielleicht kann ich eine Antibiotik um Verabreichen.
Natürlich hat der Patient stark die Patiente.
Okay, gut. Ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was mit der Frau Krüger weiter passiert und wie Ihre Ergebnisse sind.
Und dann schauen wir nachher, würden Sie sie dann nach Hause schicken oder wollen Sie sie stationär aufnehmen?
Ja, wenn die Patiente von der Datation leidet oder natürlich nach der Ergebnisse das Beurteilen,
wenn die Patiente nicht so schlecht ist, vielleicht bei der Gastronomie, die die ambulante Therapie empfehlen,
aber wenn die Patiente in der Datation ist, natürlich müssen wir die Philosophie zuvor im Zugang verabreichen.
Okay, gut. Ja, gut, ich glaube, sie waren rekordmäßig schnell jetzt im Art-Ans-Gespräch.
Sie haben sehr, sehr fix, eigentlich aber auch komplett die ganze Geschichte erklärt,
dass sie im Rahmen einer Weihnachtsfeier bei einem Essen war und ungewöhnlich scharfes Essen gegessen hat.
Das haben Sie nicht erzählt.
Das wäre vielleicht noch so ganz wichtig gewesen.
Und Magenspiegelung wurde durchgeführt, vielleicht ich sollte das erzählen.
Noch mal bitte.
Das wäre auch noch eine wichtige Geschichte.
Also tatsächlich ist dieser Fall keine Gastroenteritis, sondern die Frau hat ein Urlkursventrikoli.
Haben Sie auch nicht als Differenzialdienste?
Eigentlich, vor sechs Monaten hat die Patientin es nicht verschlagen, deswegen habe ich gedacht.
Aber ja, ein kleinischer Essen, ich fokussierte immer wegen Essen, dass das passiert.
Und da ist jetzt die Geschichte, dass man da eben unter Umständen nochmal eine Gastro wiederholt.
Wenn das andere, dass man die Gastroskopie nochmal wiederholt.
Und dann eben auch, dass man testet auf Helikobacter.
Die Patientin hat eine andere Stimmung, deswegen habe ich das auch nicht gesagt.
Bei Urlkursventrikoli ist es keine Anlage, nur ich denke.
Erwarte ich bin nicht der Fall.
Okay, ja, es ist jedenfalls so.
Und da war eben die Frage hier gestellt worden von den Prüfpann in dem Zusammenhang.
Wenn sich jetzt tatsächlich eine Helikobacter-Pylori-Infektion zeigen würde,
Was wäre das Therapie schon?
Ja, Triple Therapie, zwei Antibiotik und Protonpompon-Helmetspompon-Infektion.
Ja, okay, gut. Das ist nur der Vollständigkeit halber, weil das eine klassische Prüfernachfrage ist.
Die kommt so sicher wie sonst was.
Ja, hoffentlich können Sie fragen.
Ja, gut.
Also, vielleicht so zum Manöverkritik.
Ich hatte ein bisschen Probleme, Sie zu verstehen.
Sie sprechen relativ schnell, ich musste ein paar Mal nachfragen.
Und Sie machen tatsächlich auch noch ein paar grammatikalische Fehler.
Dass Sie also Fälle nicht ganz richtig gebrauchen oder so.
Wo mir das jetzt aufgefallen ist, dass Sie komisch formuliert haben, war bei der Familienanahmenese.
Genau, da haben Sie den Platz nicht zu Ende.
Weil der Familienanahmenese der Vater hat oder so.
Also, da muss man schon den Platz irgendwie vernünftig zu Ende.
Weil der Familienanahmenese zeigte sich für den Vater, das und das.
Und ich bin nicht jedes Mal darauf eingegangen, wenn Grammatikfehler waren.
Es ist nicht hundertprozentig perfekt.
Muss man ehrlicherweise sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die Stuttgarter drauf sind, ob die da sehr kritisch reagieren.
Könnte sein.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Es sind ein paar Unregelmäßigkeiten, wie gesagt, so von der Sprache her.
Insbesondere würde ich Ihnen aber empfehlen, versuchen Sie ein bisschen Tempo rauszunehmen.
Gerade im Arztgespräch hätten Sie ja noch sehr viel Zeit gehabt.
Und dann wäre die Verständlichkeit für den Partner deutlich besser.
Und dann gibt es vielleicht auch weniger Rückfragen.
Im Arztpatientengespräch haben Sie sich ein bisschen mehr Zeit gelassen.
Da haben Sie ja auch Ihr Zeitfenster voll ausgeschöpft.
Und da hat mir ja nicht gut gefallen, dass Sie die Patientin immer wieder mit Namen angesprochen haben.
Und dass Sie auch wirklich sehr verschiedene Formulierungen hatten,
um nach Ihren verschiedenen Beschwerden zu fragen, ist Ihnen ausgefallen.
Das haben Sie bemerkt.
Das leiden Sie unter.
Ja, Pippa Bro.
Das ist schon echt gut gewesen, fand ich.
Das hat mir sehr, sehr gut gefallen.
Und eben auch immer wieder dieses Eingehen auf das, was die Patientin schon erzählt hat.
Sie haben gesagt, das und das.
Ich habe dazu noch eine Frage.
Das haben Sie wirklich sehr schön gemacht.
Gut.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe viel von mir.
Sie waren rekordmäßig schnell.
Ja.
Dr. Kuppel, müssen wir noch irgendwas dazu sagen?
Ja, das war gut an dem Nesee und gute Patientvorstellung.
Ich denke, das gefällt mir sehr gut.
Nur Kleinigkeiten.
Sie können sagen, nicht Patient, Patient.
Können Sie sagen, Patientin.
Ach so, ja, ja.
Ja, gut.
Das ist so eine Spezialität.
Nein.
Irgendwas sagen eigentlich fast alle,
wenn das Thema kommt, dass sie sagen, Infarktus.
Das war uns, sagt das keiner.
Bei uns sagen sie Infarkt.
Aber Infarktus, ja, sagen eigentlich, glaube ich, alle Kollegen.
Ja, auch.
Da haben Sie jetzt nicht gehabt.
Kam bei Ihnen nicht vor.
Ja, auf der Tür.
Sie sagen, wir sind Infarktus.
Ja, ja, eben.
Meister Geheimlichkeiten tun wir nicht auf.
Ja, aber ich meine, ein bisschen persönliche Nose darf man ja auch aus dem Haus hören.
Gut.
Ja, wir sind am Ende.
Wir sind am Ende für dieses Jahr.
Wir sind nicht nur am Ende für heute Abend,
sondern wie gesagt, das ganze Jahr.
Es war ein Jahr mit vielen Pausen drin.
Das tut mir leid.
Ich hätte gerne manchmal ein bisschen mehr gemacht für Sie.
Ich hoffe, es war trotzdem nützlich.
Und jetzt wünsche ich also allen,
die ihre Prüfung vor sich haben.
Toi, toi, toi.
Schaffen Sie es gut.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen,
die
die Prüfung, dass Sie uns ein bisschen besser werden.
Ja, in diesem Sinne.
Ihnen einen schönen Abend auf Wiedersehen.
Wir sehen uns im neuen Jahr wahrscheinlich erst gegen Ende Januar.
Ich melde mich auf alle Fälle,
wenn es wieder losgehen kann.
Ja, und bis dahin wünsche ich Ihnen allen eine gute Zeit.
Wiedersehen zusammen.
Wir wünschen Ihnen einen guten,
vorhin neuen Jahr.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen guten,
guten Abend.
vorhin neuen Jahr.
Danke schön.
Ja.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Tschüss.